it also Bryce turned me on to so many
things in life he turned me on to star
Vadhu Valley which is a game that I
obsessed over
I also Bryce doesn't have he's not
combative in any kind of verbal is that
you try he likes a doormat yeah when you
smile I see more gums I love Donald I
love to see her gingivitis you're tall
you know what you remind me of is what's
that painter from the fifth Rockwell yes
very rare to actually meet somebody
named Bryce
very white I know Filipino named Bryce
yeah but I also know a Filipino name
like Archie and all the Greeks Filipinos
have great names greatest names on earth
Queen Elizabeth one of the greatest
monarchs great history right and then I
have a friend named twinkle that's her
government name is twinkle oh my god
my cousin's name is chick chick yeah
yeah and then my other cousins name is
Cora cookbook yeah that's and that's the
thing about names that we've forgotten
right the fun of it yeah
and I think as Americans we should name
our kids stuff that you really want it
that some monsters name is honey that's
your government name that's nice though
that's my first kid if I had it my way
first dilithium crystal I love most big
Star Trek fan
in fact the first three I would name the
second really no ten-forward award 10-4
that's where the bar is were kind and it
works will be bulwarks character I would
have a big x-men fan so adamantine steel
would be one atom for short adam no adam
entombed adamantium yeah first name and
yeah you don't well adamantium steel is
no
steel that they infused Wolverine the
closet Christine up beat it yeah I would
name one one real racist really so that
when people said his name it wouldn't
they wouldn't feel guilty ching-chong
[Music]
don't be risen that's his name right
child live with that yeah do you guys
have great children you think so
yes I think I think we need to stop
overthinking it and just do it yeah just
do it what do you have to have tweets
something's going on in show biz this is
my if it doesn't turn out well can we
drop it off at your doorstep no I got
two dogs two babies you don't want to
raise the psychotic asian baby here's
the thing because I got cray cray my
family I come from a long line of nut
bagger E and then Tommy's got his stuff
too I do think that nurture can overcome
nature and you guys are nice loving
people I don't see why you can't make it
make it happen yeah here's now they can
be so different to my first kid is a
wild man like he's Eastern European he's
gonna [ __ ] put a brick in it and be a
skateboarder and the other ones nice
social smiling yeah yeah so two
different temperaments right twice then
you can't just have bang bang and do it
do it unless the first two so that was
the two they're always but just go bang
bang just do it it's gonna be a hard few
years and then I think it gets better I
don't know I think is gonna be great for
you I have to tell you know three is my
kids three the older one it's [ __ ]
rad it gets it's so much fun
especially if you're childish and you
like to play yeah yeah and you want to
relive the fun parts of childhood yeah
it's rad I mean my house now is like
Christmas [ __ ] Christmas yeah the
whole like Christmas town and all of the
girl I did a whole Santa's Village it
lights up my tree out like that sounded
those are the things that I when I think
about wanting kids it's because I want
to give them that my Christmases my dad
was always very
he would hire my uncle to pretend to be
Santa on the roof you know like make
sounds at midnight do just the whole
thing and it was so fun for me so now I
always have this warm always the warm
fuzzies around Christmastime he never
had Christmas what I thought the Koreans
are Christian you know my dad go because
I suppose anything like 300 or great
we'd ugz Christmas for him I tried to
but initially he was very resistant and
he didn't know what to do with his body
like I would decorate I would I would
bring home a massive tree so now we do
go and get the tree and we do all that
he tries he's trying he's trying to see
the good of it yeah
but with kids that's a necessary thing
you cannot skip out on that know that I
mean if I had a kid if honestly if I had
a kid I would do everything I can to
have the kind of I've given them a
childhood that I didn't have that's what
that and that's the healing part
actually yeah it is it's simultaneous
era P before you do it though yeah
focus simultaneously you go like here's
all the stuff I never had and then you
go oh here's all this stuff I never had
so it's kind of like you go oh [ __ ] you
get angry and you get sad and that's why
that's why everyone's like it's so hard
being a parent it's not hard changing
diapers it's hard going through that
emotional stuff Wow that's what's hard
yeah because I don't remember my dad
ever like going let's go to the park
let's go anywhere yeah like I never
really hung out with them yeah you just
went to work came home got drunk beat my
mom Hungarian so they came from a lot of
trauma but the old country the Russians
took over yeah my dad drank eight
sausage washed you know the ball ball
ignored ya dated lots of women my mom
was crazy she was a she's mentally ill
so between the two of them it was like
wow yeah yeah yeah but when you have a
kid you you you heal you do heals yeah
that you know cuz that was this is the
first pitch the greatest pitch pitch to
birth yeah you're the bigger because
I talked to Natasha and Moshe yeah and
they're kind of Liz's kind of like we
love it more than our dogs right or you
see like you know Steve Byrnes daughter
Steve Burns daughter is a supermodel
she's so pretty so cute and just so and
you know and you know and then you look
al magicals or like you know that
they're smart yeah
and cute so I just had this fear that
you know mean but maybe I don't know
anyway well your kids are gonna be
gorgeous I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah this
it's this sign yes yeah what do we do on
time oh we're about over 120 Wow it's a
rom-com yeah wow there's a lot one of
the longest
[Music]